what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things YouTube channel and welcome to
Pearl daily where I cover this week's
treachery debauchery and craziness
before I start don't forget to like the
video on your way in and subscribe to
the channel also guys get yourself a
women shouldn't vote t-shirt today as
you guys know all of this craziness
started when we were told that men and
women were equal and Both Deserve equal
voting power now women have really
passed a bunch of policies that oppress
men if you think that this is awful
crazy help me to move the Overton window
and get yourself a women shouldn't vote
t-shirt today you know really you'll be
the ultimate alpha male go to the
audacity network. store that's the
audacity network. store so last night I
was sent an article now apparently I
guess some of the mainstream media
Outlets are picking up my show what a
day so I saw an article labeled the most
based man I have ever seen in my life
female Andrew Tate applauds UFC star
Shan Strickland's demand for women's
eviction from the workforce Pearl Davis
often referred to as the female Andrew
Tate by Pierce Morgan recently expressed
her support for the UFC middleweight
star Shan Strickland's controversial
call to remove women from the workforce
Shan Strickland has gained notoriety for
making sexist remarks and generating Med
attention due to his provocative and
sometimes satirical sense of humor often
for the wrong reasons during the UFC
Vegas 76 press conference Strickland
made controversial statement suggesting
that women be confined to the kitchen
and claiming that granting women the
right to vote was a mistake Pearl Davis
expressed her approval of Shan
Strickland's controversial remarks
particularly a clip where he suggested
women should be confined to the kitchen
and questioned women's right to vote
I've been saying
this thank you Sean I have been saying
this for a year now everyone says I'm
crazy now the UFC fighters are picking
it up Davis took to YouTube to voice her
support for Strickland's comments
referring to them as very based she also
found other clips from Strickland's
humorous and considered him to be a
based individual so I got a whole
article written about me because I
called somebody based wow amazing and
really what I like about Sean Strickland
is that he finds a way to bring humor
into the craziness of society really in
2023 we're living in a clown World they
think that men can be women they think
that women can be men they think that
women can work equally as hard in the
workforce and guys when I think about
women's intelligence and amazingness I
really think of women compared to
Children think about it like this if I
say that parents are better than
children nobody gets mad nobody gets
upset nobody starts crying now is there
the exceptional Prodigy child that is
just like a seven-year-old and just
super smart and amazing yes but those
are exceptions not the rule I think of
the same thing with women in the
workforce you know in general men are
better than women no that is not to be
funny yes I 100% believe that there is
the exceptional woman that is a prodigy
yes but exceptions do not make the rule
and I think that men are significantly
smarter than women now a lot of times
what people come back to me with is they
say well Pearl these IQ tests are saying
that women aggregate more in the middle
or men aggregate more on both ends of
the spectrum the reason that I don't
really subscribe to that is because I'm
not blind and I see what even high IQ
women the choices that they make in
reality I'll give you an example when we
look at the highest earning men and the
highest earning women the highest
earning women tend to capitalize on
their sexuality in some way where the
highest earning men tend to actually do
things and bring some sort of value to
the world for whatever reason women just
love to extract resources from men
through marriage and through their
sexuality where on the other hand men
really tend to provide value to the
World they invent things so I don't even
really buy this whole men are disposable
why are the women and the children
supposed to get on the life boat first
why are the men disposable the men are
the ones that invent everything the men
are the ones that do all the hard jobs
but yet the women are given all the
credit and that that's what I see I'm
not blind and so many times what they
want to do is they want to have some
leftist or liberal organization try to
tell you that you can't see what's in
front of your eyes they'll say well
here's some study or some test don't
look at what's right in front of you and
when I look at the world I'm not blind
I'm sorry guys men tend to make better
decisions they tend to provide more
value as a group to society it's not
insult to women so here is a video of
Sean Strickland um talking about this
let's pull it up Americans we need to go
back to like taking women out of the
workforce and and maybe that's and maybe
that is where we maybe that's where we
[__] up you guys we let women vote no
offense but it we but let me tell no no
I want to tell you guys something think
about America prior to women voting they
try to ban alcohol I don't even drink
but I'm not trying to ban alcohol so
what you did man you let these women
come in the workforce now we make less
money you got kids raising themselves on
[__] Tik Tok we need to go back to
like
1942 you know especially we after you
know maybe 1958 after he [__] up the
Germans we need to put women back in the
kitchen we need to take [__] only one
man needs to be working so I think as a
collective Man Group we need to elect
somebody that's going to put women back
in the kitchen put one man working
weighs the rages and build a [__]
wall have you ever thought about going
to therapy show for what I've reacted to
this clip
before oh this man is so funny this man
is so funny and he's right and it's so
funny you see even more feminine men
default to female shaming tactics so
that's what they do they'll say Sean do
you need to go to therapy and that's
what the women do to me I went to
therapy all right I did my therapy with
dalela are they happy no no and they
won't be happy because I point out the
reality and the reality is that men are
pretty much better at everything and
women's value decreases as we age but do
you know what slows down aging did you
know that one of the leading reasons
that skin begins to Sag and form
wrinkles is not necessarily because of
old age but because our bodies are
missing out on essential collagen you
see we produce 10% less collagen every
decade once we hit 30 and that's a major
reason behind those pesty wrinkles
that's why myself along with tens of
thousands of people have turned to this
Cutting Edge new substance to help
reduce visible signs of aging it uses
the top five most research types of
collagen which are essential for skin
Health to support skin elasticity and
skin hydration the best part I love is
that you get 53% off for the rest of the
month or until they sell out whatever
comes first get yours now by going to
health withth pearl.com that's Health
withth pearl.com you will not regret it
so I saw another clip this week and I
wanted to talk about the really the life
cycle that I see with only fans models
so only fans and porn workers tend to
have this life cycle they tend to do the
sex work and during the sex work they
say they have no regrets no their family
issues did not contribute to this and
they just tend to really die on the hill
that there's no regrets one example I
saw of this was I actually met um Sky
Brie when I was at no jumper a couple of
months ago and when I talked to her she
seemed to have no qualms with doing
porn until now fast forward six months a
year later she says she can't do it
anymore because she found a guy that she
loves and a lot of times what these
women want is they want to erase the
past and have no consequences for their
poor decisions you know I say do what
you're going to do um preferably not
porn if it was up to Pearl I would ban
porn but this is not Pearl's world but
don't complain about the consequences
later life is about choices and
trade-offs some women do sex work and
decide that they're going to cash out
young and die alone but what a lot of
times women want to do is they want to
do porn and have a happy ending later
and that is not the case for most of
them even if you watch porn stars that
do get married like Mia Khalifa or Lana
rhods they do get men interested in them
but the problem is they are so
desensitized that they cannot stay with
that guy so here is a clip of a woman
getting rejected on whatever podcast
because she did porn let's pull it up I
actually like you like I would I
literally have said like I would sign an
NDA and like never like let people know
about our relationship but like I
actually like actually like you so
confirm or deny are you a pathological
liar but I'm not a [__] anymore I don't
do porn anymore but I I literally said I
would stop being a [__] for you and I
literally stopped porn listen you're an
attractive woman but the fact that
you've done porn and it was a hiccup it
is a 100% a deal breaker like but I said
I'm sorry and I literally quit being a
thought your thank you for your apology
and like my pussy's like I accept I
accept your apology for doing porn Okay
um yeah it's just not going to happen
Brian why like because I used to be a
[__] like used to you still
[Music]
are she's so funny actually the one girl
has to chime in you still are yeah guys
you don't get to erase the past you
don't and you know there are things that
men will Overlook men have increasingly
accepted more and more and more in the
last hundred years it used to be
required that you were a virgin on your
wedding night now under five Partners is
considered a good deal for men today I
don't make the rules I just tell you
what they are and I'm sorry if you do
porn the odds are that you are not going
to get married the odds are not in your
favor even women that did not do porn
the odds of them getting married and
staying married and hap having that
happily ever after is actually slim to
none so the comment section chimes in
and they said I don't see an issue with
a casual night out many women past 19
aren't virgins anyway they may as well
have had three or four of you before so
why not have some fun the next comment
says there is no such thing as used to
be a [__] that's about as accurate as I
used to be white or I used to be tall or
I used to be Spanish and ladies this is
how men see it men do not forgive your
past you know God can forgive you but
men do not have to glad one du beat
she's finally realizing there are
consequences to her selfish actions this
is ironically if not comically the
epitome of f around and find out and
guys I I think I would be lying if I
said that men of the past never accepted
sex work you know I I've heard of women
that used to be strippers that got
married right I've absolutely heard of
this I've heard of this to high value
men however men are increasingly
watching the men of the past and
watching the outcome that happen for the
men that wife up [__] I'll give you an
example so many men watched Kanye wife
up Kim Kardashian now Kim Kardashian is
not wife material she does not have the
ability to get married and stay married
this is not a knock on Kim Kardashian
but I don't know how you could say that
someone that's been married three times
has the ability to be a good wife and
mother so many men watched what happened
when they picked the good-looking chick
that had dabbled in sex work before and
the outcomes that it led for Kanye now
you see yay fighting for his kids in the
Public Square in the public eye he's
complaining that his wife is letting his
children be on Tik Tock he is
complaining about the schools his wife
is sending his children to he still pays
astronomical amounts of child support
and men will ask themselves if this is
the outcome for a billionaire what are
the outcomes for me men are not looking
for marriage and relationships like they
used to and they're putting up with less
and less and less so there's a former
NBA star Joe Smith found out his wife
had a secret only fans account let's
pull it up he did that's [__] that's
[__] up I'm telling you that's [__]
up wait wait no no no C but you're not
going to say [__] me or that's [__] up
it's not [__] up [__] you recording me
what the [__] you
doing listen it's not [__] up up and
we're going to okay look so I have an
only fans page and he's mad because he's
just now finding out about it of course
I'm mad just finding out about it I'm
not doing it with anybody but myself so
why should have to tell you my choice my
body my body my [__] Choice your part
supposed to come to me and talk y I've
been talking to you about mad things
I've been asking for Solutions and [__]
you not giving me none so I created one
that's no solution not in my book that's
no solution you knew who the [__] I was
when you met me before before before met
I thought that I would never have to go
back I knew
that that's not the case after that
after that everything's supposed to
change where on Earth does this woman
think she has any leverage in this
relationship change everything did
change no no no no no obviously has no
it had to I had to do something hasn't
you stood out there showing your
body you stood out there doing stuff
like this on camera you act like that's
the only thing that I do I have mad jobs
but they're not facilitating everything
that needs to be done so I got something
extra only fans be breaking me off what
the [__] come on ke with that it don't
matter what they breaking you off it's
the disrespect that comes with it disres
you couldn't come and talk to me about
it okay well we're talking about it now
cuz I had to find out on the fly all
right then but now okay I had to find
out on the
Fly
so now you
know yeah now I
know
okay and
so
whatever I'm been doing what I have to
do period like that's bottom line that's
what it is this is grounds for this is
grounds for a divorce she is publicly
committing adultery this this is
absolutely I I'm very anti- divorce guys
but this is grounds for a divorce and
this is why I believe that in general
men should be able to divorce women but
women should not be able to divorce men
I know that sounds crazy but women will
continue to test the men that they are
with and push the boundaries and push
their buttons and women continue to act
up if they don't think that divorce is
on the table the same way that an
employee will act up if they don't think
they can get fired this is grounds for a
divorce and you know one thing that she
said was you knew I was like this when
you met me why do women think that they
should be able to act the exact same
when they're married when they're single
women of the past knew this they knew
there was a way that you act when you're
single and you act when you are married
being married was a role that women
realized they had to fulfill that had
specific duties and now you have a woman
that is married to an ex-nba player that
was complaining about money now I I know
that sometimes NBA players have money
problems after but you know she has fake
nails on she has fake hair she has heavy
makeup on you know maybe she just wants
a lifestyle they can't afford anymore
and women care more about the lifestyle
that they love to live than they do
about their own families she has brought
shame upon her entire family where are
we at in society when wives and mothers
have zero shame and really I think think
that men need to learn an important
lesson from this and the comment section
are telling them once a hoe always a hoe
like if you agree you cannot change
women you can't Bluegrass says stop
trying to make a hoe a wife yes denote
gun I wouldn't argue with her just leave
exactly because when you argue with a
chick you're basically saying you're on
her level the same way when a boss is
actually arguing with an employee you
know it's on the boss too but men have
been told that they are doing the right
thing by wiping up single mothers and
Born Again
virgins it is not the right thing and it
has catastrophic effects on your family
on your children this is a woman that
you are trusting with the most important
thing on the planet your kids so again
this is why I have the controversial
opinion men should be able to divorce
women but women should not be able to
divorce men except in cases of abuse yes
fine guys I'll give you you divorce from
an abuser all right a real abuser not
the abuse you guys call abuse nowadays
um okay so teenager who murdered
boyfriend in a 100 mile per hour crash
had a toxic relationship with him the
prosecutor said McKenzie schrill a
19-year-old from Ohio was found guilty
of 12 counts including four counts of
murder for intentionally crashing her
car at 100 milph in July of 2022
resulting in the death of her boyfriend
Dominic Russo and his friend Davon
Flanigan prosecutors argued that shrill
had a toxic and tumultuous relationship
with Russo including violent threats and
she deliberately crashed the car to end
their relationship during the trial
security video of the crash was
presented as evidence the judge strongly
condemned shr's actions characterizing
the crash as methodical deliberate and
intentional and purposeful the judge
stated that this was not reckless
driving but an act of murder emphasizing
that the deliberate nature of the crash
and its devastating consequences some
key quotes and details from the case
include her actions were controlled
methodical deliberate intentional and
purposeful this was not reckless driving
this was murder said the County Common
Please judge Nancy Margaret Russo she
had a mission and she executed it with
Precision the mission was death judge
Russo added chill's father expressed a
desire not to see Sha's life ruined and
called her actions a damn stupid thing
incidents highlighted in the trial
included Sha's threats to crash the car
in the weeks leading up to the fatal
crash in videos from Russo's cell phone
capturing veral abuse and threats from
shrill shrill had posted on social media
expressing her grief over Russo's death
and remorse for her actions with
statements like I miss you nug I wish
you were just going to walk through the
door any second please wait for
me so women are much more violent and
much more calculated than we give them
credit for and I think one archetype
that I see in society is the enabling
father and this is the father that
constantly babies and caters to his
daughter he puts his daughter on a
pedestal as a princess that can do no
wrong to the point where you have a dad
referring to murder is a damn stupid
thing however typically these dads if
they had a son that did the same thing
and killed a load of women they would
have a lot less empathy for them and
realize that when you commit a crime you
have to do the time but women are so
used to being bailed out of their bad
decisions and for a lot of women it
starts at Birth it starts at Birth when
their parents treat them differently
than the boys in the family and really
we have such a guy entric social order
that we say to young women you are so
special and amazing and awesome all the
time even if you've done nothing to
deserve it and enabling fathers lead to
bratty daughters that is why you have
the children throwing temper tantrums
that is why you have the children doing
things like this because they have a
lack of discipline in their life and
really a lot of these women don't see
consequences until they get into middle
age and their skin start sagging and did
you know that one of the leading raisin
skin begins to Sag and form wrinkles is
not necessarily because of old age but
because our bodies are missing out on
essential collagen you see we produce
10% less collagen every decade once we
hit 30 and that's a major reason behind
those pesty wrinkles adding just a
little collagen to your diet can have
noticeable effects for your skin and
youthfulness preferably the sooner the
better that's why myself along with tens
of thousands of people have turned to
this Cutting Edge new substance to help
reduce visible I signs of aging it uses
the top five most researched types of
collagen which is essential for skin
Health to support skin elasticity and
skin hydration these five collagen types
are difficult to find on their own but
they're included in every scoop just mix
a serving with your favorite morning
drink to give skin the building blocks
it needs to reignite a youthful glow the
best part I love is you get 53% off for
the rest of the month or until they sell
out whatever comes first plus you'll
also receive additional gifts valued at
over $500 free with every order for a
limited time including free VIP live
health and fitness coaching a new ebook
titled the 14 foods for amazing skin a
60-day satisfaction guarantee with free
shipping get yours now by going to
health withth pearl.com that's Health
withth pearl.com you will not regret it
so guys our last topic today you know
more and more the older I get and the
more I start covering these stories I
see how in the US we put up with a lot
of [__] we really do other countries
aren't all like this so China suppresses
feminist lgbtq groups outside of China
they seek to rebuild so the Chinese
government is cracking down on queer and
feminist groups as part of its broader
control over Civil Society in response
Chinese speaking communities outside of
China are creating spaces for free
expression one such example is the
feminist talk show in New York City
where Mandarin chinesee speaking
individuals use spoken World standup
comedy and skits to strategize misogyny
and political repression the generation
of the Chinese dysphoria is well
educated and adapt at navigating both
American and Chinese culture why can't
the West just respect cultures that do
not put up with this stuff that is part
of western culture all of this woke
nonsense and there are parts of the
world that do not accept that as part of
their culture why does the West feel the
need to try to infiltrate these people's
cultures they use comedy as a tool to
express their thought particularly
concerning topics that are censored or
restricted in China the organizers film
each other's performances and share it
on social media for the Chinese
audiences although these videos are
often removed due to the Chinese
government's hardening stance on
lgbtq issues the government views
lgbtq groups as potential threats of
foreign influencers that undermine its
pro- nationalist goals these communities
like feminist talk show provide a
platform for cosmopolitan young Chinese
people to express themselves and engage
in a quiet form of resistance by
discussing their experiences related to
queer and feminist issues this allows
them to raise awareness and contribute
to the discussion especially those
living outside China where their voices
are more challenging for the Chinese to
sign silence
yeah I think this is wrong I think that
you know in the US we have freedom of
speech you are welcome to talk about
whatever you want to talk about however
I think that it is wrong to try to
Target a country that does not accept
that and I'll give you an example guys I
went to a feminist event and I'm
actually mad because the footage we got
from it it didn't really stick so
whatever but um we got to we got to get
better like undercover camera footage
you guys have to help me if you guys
know any good like um equipment let me
know in the comments but okay so we went
to this event and literally they were
talking about the strategies to
implement abortion in countries that do
not accept that so they named some
countries in Africa the Middle East and
I was disgusted how these groups that
will actively say they're oppressed feel
the need to push their culture onto
other people why can't you just go be a
crazy person by yourself yourself and
not put it on the rest of the world why
do you have to and their ideas included
getting abortion pills under a different
um so basically if you broke your leg or
I I don't remember the exact way they
did it but one way they wanted to do it
was putting an abortion pill under like
say you break your leg you know that
pill gives you abortions and putting it
under a different name or sending it in
the mail and really their point was they
can't stop us we're going to infiltrate
these places and I think that's wrong I
don't understand why you can't just
respect cultures that are different than
yours and throughout it they'll scream
oppression when they're in when they're
making money off of their ideas in a
country that allows them to speak so let
me know what you guys think in the
comments make sure you like the video on
your way out and subscribe to the
channel and I will talk to you next time